LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
This is an incredible place
with lots of great stuff being
worked on every single day.
Before I worked here,
I always wondered
what it would be like to
come to the Googleplex,
meet up with a Googler
and have coffee with them,
and just chat about what
they do, how they do it
and why they do it.
And today, we're going
to do exactly that.
Welcome to "Coffee
With A Googler."
Today, I'm meeting
with Ryan Troll,
who's a technical team lead.
He's responsible for helping
you build better, faster,
safer secure login systems.
Welcome, Ryan, and thanks
for joining us today.
RYAN TROLL: Glad to be here.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So tell us, what
is it that you do at Google?
RYAN TROLL: I work with
teams around the globe trying
to make sure that you, and only
you, sign into your account.
We try to keep the attackers
out, and as a side effect,
keep your data as
safe as possible.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So how is
it you go about doing that?
Can you share a little bit?
RYAN TROLL: Sure.
We look at everything we can
try to determine whether or not
it's really you signing in.
We can't go into
too many details,
because, well-- the attackers
are listening as well.
But we'll give an
example that's easy,
that everybody can understand.
Where'd you grow up?
LAURENCE MORONEY: I
grew up in Ireland.
RYAN TROLL: Ireland.
So let's say that
one of your relatives
who's currently still in Ireland
travels to visit you here
in the States, and they come
to Google while they're here
to read their Gmail.
As they start to sign
in, we'll look at that
and say, well, you know what?
This person's never visited
the States before, never
signed in from here before,
or they've done it very, very
infrequently.
We should ask a few
other questions,
make sure it's really them.
So we look at
patterns, et cetera,
like that, to make sure that the
person logging is really them.
This way, we would stop
an attacker in the States
from trying to, in this case,
log in as your relative.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
RYAN TROLL: Now, we've invested
a lot of time and energy
into making sure that
our web sign-in flows.
The thing you see every day
when you go to log into Gmail
are as secure as possible, and
revolving that day in, day out.
However, it's a
little harder to do
that for our programmatic
sign-in flows.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So what
makes it so difficult
to do programmatic access?
RYAN TROLL:
Programmatically access
does not offer a
web interface for us
to extend and expand to allow
users to provide extra data.
So, let's do a little
history lesson here.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I
love history lessons.
RYAN TROLL: Great.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Bring it on.
RYAN TROLL: Years
ago, we-- we, Google--
decided to offer a
bunch of public APIs
and allow users to begin to
write really rich applications.
These could be web applications.
Nowadays, they're
smartphone applications.
We wanted those applications
be able to have access
to your calendar, contacts,
personal data, et cetera.
In order to do that,
those applications
had to be able to run as you.
The easy way to do that was to
give that application your name
and password, and that
application would provide
that name and password
to Google through an API
we called client login, and
in return, get a credential
they could use to
access your data.
This has worked for years.
Many, many, many applications
have built on top of that.
Many, many attackers have used
that to maliciously gain access
to accounts as well, because
it's an easy way to script
turning, comparing a
username and password
and make sure it's correct.
We can look at that
request coming in,
and maybe decide that we
don't want to service it,
because we think it
might be an abuser.
But all we can do,
programmatically, is say no.
We can't go and ask further
additional questions.
This is a bit of a problem.
It's something we
can do on the web,
but we can't do it
programmatically.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Got it.
Got it.
Now, you mentioned
client login there,
and I know client login
is something that has been
recently deprecated, right?
RYAN TROLL: Three
years ago, we announced
that client login was deprecated
and that we were going
to turn it off in April, 2015.
It's been turned off.
We no longer allow developers
to write applications
that collect names and passwords
and submit them to Google.
Instead, we've been encouraging
for years, developers
to use a OAF as a means
of building applications
that have access to your data.
OAF, emerging standard, has come
around over the last few years.
It's a fantastic way
to, as an application,
obtain access to
users data because it
doesn't require you
to collect and store
a username and password.
More importantly,
as an application,
you can request exactly
what data you want.
Now, if you have downloaded
an application that's,
for example, a
contact manager, it
allows you to add
and remove pictures
for your contacts, et cetera.
That application only has
access to your contacts.
Three years ago,
with client login,
the same application would
have had your password
and actually been to
do anything-- send mail
as you, et cetera.
Whereas as a user,
you now get to know
exactly what every
application does, and can,
if you wanted to,
through the magic of OAF,
actually say, that application
should no longer work for me
and turn just one off.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I see.
Got it.
That makes it a lot more
secure, and a lot safer.
RYAN TROLL: A lot
safer, and gives users
a lot more control over who's
accessing what-- something we
really are invested in.
LAURENCE MORONEY: With
the deprecation of client
login-- and I know
it's something
you've been talking
about for some time--
but there was a recent blog
post pointing developers
at new resources
that they could find.
Could you tell us a
little bit about that?
RYAN TROLL: Sure.
We did a final farewell to
client login in April of 2015.
We had been working on
that for about three years.
At that time, all
client login based
applications stopped
working, and we've
been encouraging developers to
move to a combination of a OAF
in order to obtain fine grained
access to user data and OpenID
Connect, which gives users the
sign in with Google experience.
Both of these are documented
online in the account
cookbook we provide.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
Cool.
The the link, we'll just
share it underneath, here.
RYAN TROLL: Great.
Cool.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Please click that.
So given that security is
so important, and given
that it's really difficult
to roll your own security
infrastructure, do you have any
tips for developers or any ways
that they can get
started in building
good, secure, safe systems?
RYAN TROLL: Absolutely.
I'd give three big pointers.
First pointer would be to
go and read up on OAF2.
It's the emerging standard
for providing granular access
to user data.
It's an open standard--
it's used by many sites
around the net.
Once you know what
to look for, you'll
see it's used everywhere.
I don't want to name
any sites that use it.
The second one is
OpenID Connect,
which is really the
standard-- emerging
standard-- behind the sign
in with Google experience.
Once again, many, many
sites are using it.
The third technology
I'd suggest looking at
is something we call the
Google Identity Toolkit, which
is a generic set of libraries
that help facilitate identity
management across providers
allowing you to build
your applications without having
to spend all your time thinking
about, how do I manage
user passwords, et cetera.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thanks, Ryan.
I've learned a lot
about client login.
I was wondering
what to do about it.
I'll take a look
at those resources
that you've mentioned.
I've been reading a little bit
about the Identity Toolkit,
and there's some
great stuff there.
Thanks for watching this episode
of "Coffee With A Googler."
I hope you learned as
much as I did today.
If you want to learn more
about developing with Google,
take a look at the Google
Developers channel.
There's lots of great episodes
of "Coffee With A Googler"
there, as well as hundreds
more videos about everything
that you might be
possibly interested in.
If you've any questions
for me or for Ryan,
just please leave them
in the comments below.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]